this week we're talking about everything
iö tensor processing and more welcome to
this week in cloud where we serve you
the lowest latency news last week was
i/o and where I overwhelmed with cool
Google things to show off if you're
looking for one convenient place to find
all the cloud updates head on over to
the Google cloud blog we've compiled all
the announcements and noteworthy news
into one post full of useful information
like exactly what's changing and why it
matters for developers plus you can
check out the Google developers blog to
read more about the other areas like
chrome and Android here are some of our
favorites you may already be familiar
with tensor processing units the chip
that we built specifically to speed up
the development of ml applications
well now we're giving you access to TPU
v2 and v3 pods in beta TPU pods are like
a supercomputer of TP use strapped
together and running jobs in hours that
used to take weeks read more about what
they do and try using one in the
interactive collab from startup to
enterprise firebase is all about making
mobile and web app development easier
and we saved some big announcements for
i/o major improvements to the ml kit
bring the power of Google's ml expertise
to your app through API is like on
device translation firebase performance
monitoring lets you see how to visualize
where your web apps may be slowing down
while the updated audience builder helps
you make smarter decisions for your user
base read more about the details and
build some amazing user experiences
everyone wants to make great predictions
with their data but you can't do that
without preparing it first if you want
to transform your data without using
complex systems look no further than
data prep we've got a new blog post that
looks at how to use data prep and gives
you an idea of a three-step data quality
workflow from assessing your data set to
resolving issues and validating at scale
follow along with the example or open up
the console and try it out on your own
data if you want to read more about
these announcements or see a full list
check out the link have any thoughts or
ideas leave us a comment or tweet us
we'll see you in the cloud
you